If I recall, John, when you proposed the idea to Nate and I, um, you said, like, look, I kind of want
to use the podcast as an opportunity to just try to get a handle on the things I, I, I am in that state
where I don't really have a critical orientation to it, so I said, and I hadn't read anything about it,
I kind of just mentioned that, you know, we're gonna do, um, an episode on it to Tony, Tony Stagliano.
and he hadn't watched it either but, like, at least was aware that there was some kind of controversy
about it, so I was prepared for it to be, you know, like, not really sure what direction it would take
me in, and I thought it was the funniest fucking thing I've watched in a long time. It made me laugh
like all the time. I mean, like, I mean the intellectual engagements that I had, which I
think will, you know, drive our conversation and will be the most interesting things
long term, were not driving me actually watching. I just thought it was good and really, really funny.
I might change my opinion over the course of this conversation.
Yeah, I mean, I came into it like almost feeling like I'd already watched it, just because I'd heard
of so many different opinions, both on Twitter from friends. My parents had watched it, and it seems like
at least on the Twitter verse, everybody either viciously hated it or was saying it was like this
experimental genius work of art. And so I was kind of skeptical going in. I also feel like the reception
was a little similar to, uh, Nanette, um, you know, because it marketed itself as a comedy special
but it wasn't explicitly or it wasn't overtly, like, it wasn't packed with jokes. It was a lot of like, uh,
criticism, reflection on the state of comedy, which is also like how the Beau Burnham special starts
and ends. It's like talking about comedy rather than like explicitly pushing jokes all the time, um, but
I mean, I don't know, because we were watching it as like food for conversation in the podcast, I feel
like I had a different orientation towards it than I would just picking it up on Netflix casually. So I, I was
finding interesting stuff throughout, but I was reading it like a text, you know what I mean? Like as we would
uh, something, you know, the Lose or Heidegger or whatever. Um, but I liked it. I mean, I didn't dislike
it, so yeah. No, that's interesting. It's funny because I, I had watched it before kind of the hype, just
because I had been anticipating it. I follow Beau Burnham on Twitter and but a lot of like Gen Z people
were resurfacing his old stuff, and this was weeks before he'd even mentioned really that he was coming
up with a new special. So he had kind of been on the brain, and I checked in to see what he's up to, and
anyways when I first watched it I actually had to stop watching it because I got so depressed when
I saw it, um, but at the same time I think there is certainly a humor to it. I think like I thought
and and that was a very uh good point because I felt the same way that initially when I started
watching it I was like uh what's the word I don't know I feel like it's not in the conventional kind
of funny that we're used to right but there aren't jokes I mean there are not very many jokes there are
a few but there aren't very many exactly but I think honestly like his line towards the end when
he was saying like you know the tone of him talking about how he wanted to get back into comedy right
before Covid and he's like and the funniest thing happened and it's like that dark satire irony I feel
like that's like the most pervasive theme of like and I don't know you just have that really pun
funny feeling as you watch it too like it was kind of sickening in a way but at the end like I felt
it was I actually know I wouldn't even say it's rewarding. I felt like really empty after watching
it. I'm not gonna lie I feel like I kind of ruined the pandemic so that's my take it's an interesting
I mean that's this is just a side note but it was interesting to me and I was really palpably aware
of it the second time I watched it like he never mentions Covid he never mentions the pandemic like
it's not mentioned even alluded to right like other than the funniest thing happened that's the only
time and it's all left out there and like and yet we as viewers watching this now you don't have to
mention it it's super obvious every single person knows what the constitution of that year why did
he stay inside for a year we all know he doesn't have to explain it right like and I thought about
that like the idea of the sort of staying power of you know works of art it's like in 20 years that's
not going to make sense no right I mean or longer like it's just not going to make sense because he
doesn't reference it he does there's no frame there's no gesture to it it is just like people
are going to think he was just depressed he was just holding himself up as opposed to being actually
stuck yeah it is interesting though considering in his career he was out of comedy for five years
Doing just that's right, so in conversation with, like, watching it, you know, 20 years from now, it might
still have the same, like, resonance, but I also think, like, from a media perspective, if you watch it
and you don't understand the context, like, it has that sort of, like, temporary fleeting of, like, live
comedy, like, in a weird kind of meta way. So I don't know, something had he he quit comedy or something did
did he quit live performing, sending panic attacks? He said, oh, okay, yeah, really depressed. And he alludes
to that. Like, I mean, even in, like, I recently rewatched his 2016 Be Happy, and it has, like, and I would
say it was really more like the last, like, five minutes he really gets into, like, I'm so tired of
this. I am so depressed, like, I'm, I'm done basically. When did he start? Do you know? Like, was he really
young? Was he like 16 when he got his start? Yeah, he was a YouTube video. Yeah, there's a clip of it in
this, in the, in the special of him watching himself. He has just commented on, like, turning the turning
ourselves over or turning our brains over to these, like, corporations, and it's, he's, and then he's
watching himself as a 16-year-old play the song that, like, went viral. And what's interesting though
wasn't even one. So I was looking at his Wikipedia page. So what got him started wasn't even so much
that he did a song and it went viral, so he he'd sent he put it on YouTube, like, for his family to
share and that kind of picked up traction, but then from there he wrote a whole album. So it wasn't as
if this was a one-hit wonder and he got all the fame at once, like, it kind of changes the narrative
and his own cynicism that in a way he kind of bought into it, like he saw, like, I mean, that definitely
sparked it, but like it wasn't like there was a turn. Like, 2006 was when that video came out, the first one
and 2008 he already had a deal with Comedy Central and he was like, oh wow, I didn't realize that. Yeah,
so it's like interesting kind of the interplay is like on one hand he's so critical, but it's not
like he didn't have a choice going into this industry and like having this like he was fully bought in
which is not like a bad thing but no but it's obviously something that I mean, you know, obviously
he's wrestling with that, like his role as, you know, and that to me is one of the recurring motifs is
you know, my role as a uh cultural critic who's still participating in the culture, which one of
the things that struck me, Caroline, just from our conversations about your job at at Turner, right?
like that's a question that you struggle with, right? Like is okay on the one hand I'm really interested
in perpetuating the arts and doing something interesting with this sort of creativity and
productions and and on the other hand I'm working for a giant, you know, global corporation who
you know, so so having to balance those questions. So it is it's it's generationally appropriate, like
for folks entering the the the non-academic workforce. It's like that's a real problem that you have to
wrestle with that in ways my generation didn't have to. I mean, I guess it just depends on who you are
but like we didn't wrestle with as much and academia is a different industry altogether. Yeah, we have to
wrestle with that as well. I mean, what we put kids in crazy debt every year. Yeah.
That's true. I mean, the corporate university. I mean, it is sort of its own system, but it still
runs similarly, you know, there there's our culp, there's a culpability in corporate uh values
in any industry basically at this point, you know, including comedy, which she alludes to again and again
throughout the special. But is that interplay that I enjoyed the most? I mean, you know, we're talking
about whether it's comedy or whether it's funny or whatever else, and you know, like the for me, the
best comedy is always played with the line between what's a joke and not a joke, you know, that is
is a good example. I mean, I think Chapelle for a long time, um, you know, the um uh was it um
what's the uh the sketch comedy, Bob Newkirk, um, yeah, the show. Yeah, I mean, all of those sorts of
things. I mean, that Bob and Dave, which which don't, you know, kind of assert or at least they problematize
the kind of, you know, funny serious binary as like what like terrible serious depressing things are
not antithetical to to humor, that they like they can also be funny and terrible at the same at the
same time and that doesn't simply make it like okay and you know I I find often what we're trying to do
in categorizing something as, you know, comedy or not comedy, is we're trying if we license it as comedy
then we're free to laugh at it without being on the hook for the thing. But then if it slips
over into something else then we have to be more safeguarded with our reactions to unless we be
complicit in something that's bad and what i like about comedies that that blur that boundary is like
you you're gonna laugh and be complicit at the same time and you don't really get to pick and
Choose and in fact not like it's actually finding that license to laugh without being on the hook
And that's the scary thing. That's the kind of, you know, purity-seeking fascistic thing that's
like, that is, I get to laugh at this thing because I've been sanctioned to do it, I've been allowed to
do it well, and that made a really good point, uh, in that special if you have you, I guess you guys have
all seen it, everyone kind of brought it up about the whole idea of comedy being tension and release and
like the self-awareness too of like as you're talking and telling this really dark, not even a joke, it just
becomes this um it's all attention and release kind of thing and like how much more significant those
releases are and why I think those that kind of comedy is more effective as a medium because it's
so controversial and you do have like that freedom to laugh because you really aren't sure if you're
allowed to versus like the simple ha-ha funnies it's like well of course I'm gonna laugh at that
versus the like oh this is kind of a scandalous laughter but I actually sort of think that this
is different insofar as there isn't really release right like Nanette does give you that and then she
takes it away right like Hannah Gadsby gives you that in that in that special right she and she shows
you how she's doing it and she does it but there isn't a release it's all like there's nothing that in
in this in terms of the cultural criticism and then moving into the depression question like
there's none of it that's that's just like oh I can laugh at this now right like it's all filled
with it there's no simple it's not like there's a dialectic between tension and release it's like
tension release all the time I agree I would say though I do think the musical numbers more so in
the first half like Welcome to the Internet and like little snippets within definitely like
contributed to somewhat of a release I think also too like I have the bias which I feel like most
people who did go into it knowing Bo Burnham understanding his style and like that his kind
of music is just so funny to me even if it's not even if it's not as clever or as funny as he usually
is because I know his style of comedy and like watched him kind of grow so I I don't know I felt
to me the most tense parts was the voyeuristic aspects of it as we all I'm sure you know but the
songs I thought that those actually in a way were like the most relief that you can kind of take a
second and I don't know I wasn't really reflecting I was kind of just enjoying like the wit of it and
so that was like that and look I love how he takes the genres I mean the musical genres and what he does
with the musical genres is is nothing I was just like oh that's a brilliant you know yeah a way of
using that genre of music but think of something like the sock puppet um one of them the Socko right like
like it's it's the kids I mean it's done is this it's the kids comic thing and this is how the world
works and he tells this nice I mean in that first part he tells this nice story about like how you know
ecological everything is connected and we all work together and the fish in the sea and everything and
then it's like actually it's about sort of abusive exploitative power and genocide and that's sort of
Socko and then he performs it in an accident his relationship you know with the sock puppet so that's what I mean
it's like what seems like this kind of silly juvenile thing becomes like oh fuck this is
this is kind of intense right like and and and brutal right like I mean obviously it's a sock puppet
and whatever but I mean it's there's a brutality to the end of that thing it's just like the the
extent to which the sock puppet is now cowed into submission and we'll sing along the sing the song along
with him you know after he you know so and also I mean for me I love that what went from that sort of
likeable childhood Mr. Rogers-y type voice is still that Mr. Rogers-y type voice but he's like you will
obey me you know and it's like I mean that that's what I mean of there's a maybe a maybe a closer
relationship between the tension release so that it's not like build up tension ah release we get
to laugh for a little bit it's like there's no time where you just get to laugh I think maybe I'm
gonna rephrase what I initially said I don't think it was released in the sense that it was like that
tension that was built up was finally alleviated I think it was kind of like a kind of like passing
a kidney stone that definitely it got out but I think it's almost like in levels of extreme because
when you look at that scene in particular I felt you know midway as he starts you know darkening it
I was like oh shit but then we can swear in this right oh yeah okay excellent um but then at the
very finale of it when it got super dark you know the world is made of blood it was so intense that I
laughed harder than I would have out of the absurdity and insanity of it all so it wasn't like a traditional
like, oh, you know, like this is really funny but i think almost he works in these incredible lows but
that incredible highs that are still equally dark but also just so insanely dark that it almost like
flips it in a way that is a very good release and that's what i mean and so that's that's different
than Hannah Gadsby she does not do that yeah that next move you know and i i do think that that is
interesting i i agree with you yeah i mean what i really i mean to stick with the Mr. Sacco example is
how seamless the transitions are within that the genre of the kids um show where he seamlessly like
the seamless you know like i mean you have no idea you're passing in you know through this liminal space
like into the sock telling you about like the world being made of blood and then you know like he's
singing along with him and then and then like the seamless transition into the exertion of power over
the puppet is like part of what is incredibly unnerving and terrifying about it but then the
dramatization of that back and forth and i i totally agree with caroline that that you know there is
there is a that the release is yeah kind of like passing the kidney stone rather than being allowed to
laugh you're never allowed to laugh but it's sort of like you have to in response to well it is i mean
it is that baseline question and i think it's one i mean i want to throw out like because i think
i mean he doesn't resolve it and he doesn't resolve a lot of the questions which is great he doesn't
need to you know um but you know the question he raises right at the beginning which is you know is
it should i be joking at a time like this right and and he means that initially he means that in terms
of the world situation right he means sort of social circumstances can one do comedy what role does comedy
server can comedy serve in the context in the social context it then turns in the second half because that's
also right at the end he says the exact same thing in one of the sort of closing songs but it's in
relationship to his mental state right in other words this is no longer a social question this is
a sort of personal personal question like should i be making jokes about my you know depression right
and and that's actually one of the things that bugs me about that not bugs is not the right word but
has kind of grated on me a little bit is that there's a way of of watching the episode as a
devolution from social criticism to mental health deterioration such that the social criticism would
be like a nascent version uh uh you know what i mean and that was one of the things this sort of
transformation from the first half which is cultural commentary cultural criticism funny and whatever you
know to like i'm depressed and thinking of ending things and and whatnot you know like
it it personalizes it like i wish it hadn't ended how it ended i wish there had been a turn you know one
more turn at the end to bring it back to the social and not you know what i mean like that that was to
me that because it's just like it just became there was a way in which the arc of it just transitioned from
the social to the personal and that's where we sort of stopped yes a sort of problematic re-entry into the
the social at the end but nevertheless like yeah i felt not only thematically but just in terms of
rhythm and pace it just slowed down i mean maybe it was just too a little bit too long i think it
could have ended in an hour what was it an hour and a half something around there i just felt a little
bit of exhaustion with both the content and the sort of pacing of it i felt like i know it was sort of
almost more musical than it was comedic or it was some sort of synth synthesis but i also felt like
there was too many songs and like i hit a wall with the songs at about an hour like 50 minutes and
i was like i would like just some Bo Burnham talking i mean i get this is what it is but like
so i just felt rhythmically like you're talking about the content shifts from critical commentary
social commentary to personal reflection i felt like just compositionally it was a brilliant piece
but it felt like he could have made some editing decisions it could have been 50 minutes you know
what i mean instead of an hour and a half it wouldn't have given you the tension though it wouldn't have
given you i mean i think that because i agree with you in the sense that i was pretty uncomfortable for
the last 20 minutes watching it um because there was a lot of just him sitting right there's like
still shots the silences were kind of nice and shots of him starting starting to speak and not being able to
speak and starting again you know like um and so and i think that i mean i get what you're saying
as you're watching it but i think in terms of the scope of the thing that's what he's trying to do
it's like that's that's the project here and he talks about like not giving a shit whether you're
paying attention or not but also caring there's the one song where he's like i don't even want to
know if you're bored like I don't care I'm going to keep going I'm going to keep plotting forward yeah
there is that that shift where yeah like the the working on the project is the thing that's keeping
him going and talking about that big transition you know that the first you know like one of the very
first songs it's all like there's almost the the Monty Python search for the Holy Grail like God descends
from the skies to put him on his quest to use comedy to save the social and then you know he kind of
that that shift turns to comedy just allowing him to continue to live right right I think it is also
interesting though given the medium that we're watching it on because unlike a normal comedy special I mean
obviously yes we're more accustomed to seeing comedy specials but those are pre-recorded specials
in a live audience setting whereas Bo Burnham intentionally made this to be streamed and exclusively
streamed and I mean again I don't want to imply this like genius on a person who hasn't really
explained his you know piece in a way but I do think it's interesting how we watch it because I
personally I had to stop it because I was I mean partially you know I was just kind of like whoa
this is like a lot to process I was looking for something fun but also I agree with you guys I
mean it is like exhausting it is uncomfortable so but it is like fascinating too like that extra
layer of self-reflection that may not have even been Bo Burnham's intention that it's like I can
actually sit and pause and watch this and I have despite the fact that it's his show you have the
control is you know how much of it that you actually watch you know like I think that I don't know added
a different element to it of like so so that's interesting because I think then maybe we all had this
experience because I actually the first time I watched it I stopped it with about 25 minutes left
because I was like I can't go here right now um and it was like late at night or whatever and then
like this is just getting too intense like I've gotta I gotta go watch Modern Family or something
silly you know what I mean um it's meta in a way too that you're you know you're watching him pause
and start and pause and start and like not that it's influencing you to do the same but it's like
you're complicit and also the inability to start and finish something too you know that's really good
that's an important point right I that's a really to me the the I mean when you're thinking about the
rhythm Nate like the the stopping and starting dimension of this thing is is like you know I mean
very little until the end very little is more than three minutes long like I go like I took different
margin notes every time a new scene a new shot occurred in the scene and there I mean for a 90 minute
special there's probably I don't know 30 of them right like 30 different sort of shots and that's
incredible like just in terms of the the pacing of the thing yeah it is very much so cut like an album
and it what has been released is just an album you know there's the intermission there's the A side
there's the B side there's about you know 12 to 15 songs on each on each you know side so that's I
mean that that makes sense you know to me think about you know somewhere between like
three to five minutes for a song yeah I mean it almost invites you to pause it and then come back
at a week later a day later yeah and I've heard like on the metrics on Netflix so a traditional
comedy special is what an hour an hour and 15 and it it wants you to watch the whole thing all at once
because if you're in the live audience you're not gonna get up you can't pause it so it wants you to
sort of but what they found uh the in the metrics is that basically the average listening time for
anything on Netflix but particularly comedy specials is 30 minutes 20 minutes at a time so people are
pausing them and then coming back at a later date and this one I think it's almost explicitly invites
you to do that oh it's not forcing you to keep watching I mean you can pause it wherever you want
and come back to a later sketch and keep going I am then what you would call a statistical outlier
because I I can't do that I I plow through and you know this one I watched all the way through and
then when I realized I had the wrong podcasting time I started it up again and I mean well you
saved it to the day of the podcast of course you had to watch it you have incentive I know but I had
no desire to I'm like this with everything I never pause things I never come back to them I mean like
I'll come back to them to watch them again but I don't pause and then and pick it back up like I
I have just like I have never fallen asleep to a TV show I have never fallen asleep to the TV on I have
to I am yeah like completely locked in and I agree yeah it is weird I know but it's explain if you guys
are in academia because I I personally could my attention span I mean again pop probably generational
As well, but um yeah it's it's interesting because I I all the people that I've talked to also stopped
and started and that kind of goes back to the whole internet a little bit of everything all the time so
yeah that's right that's right staccato I couldn't personally yeah yeah yeah but I was I wanted to
come back to the it being too long so I I agree as sort of like a tidy, you know, content package it is
too long but think about the number of times he's um sort of attending to the industry of content
production and so all of those little like hitches and glitches and showing the shots of him moving
things and the uncomfortable silences and the on the too longness like is I I think a way of of like
you know punctuating those contents and making I mean like I I in a weird way liked being made
to feel uncomfortable there yeah yeah and his ability to put on those different masks I mean basically
points to his talent as an actor too because I agree with that when he when he's pretending to be the
branding manager oh yeah that was great yeah there's and there's obviously a few others I mean he
really embodies those roles and I feel like some viewers probably didn't even pick up on the the
irony of of certain bits like especially when he's making fun of himself as a a white comedian woke
comedian I think a lot of people probably just invested in him like they thought he was being sincere
because there are moments of sincerity they're they're kind of few uh well I don't know there's
spring I don't even know I mean yeah I'm gonna pull back there are there's a real yeah that's a real
question because and it relates to this issue for me it starts with the setting up of the equipment and
the showing of the production right this sort of standard meta move of the last 50 years which is show the
making of the thing while you're also making it but of course there's always a blind spot
right like there's always a necessary blind spot in showing that because you can't show the camera
right if you're showing yourself setting up cameras there's a camera that you can't show
right like and and you're you're so there's always that hidden secret portal like that's always being
displaced so as much and so to me I'm actually like maybe it's just that I've seen too many of
those types of things it's like I get that you're showing us that this is uh artifice um but you can't
show that it's artifice like you you just can't fully do that and so therefore to me it always sort
of fails in its attempt to show you that thing and I'm like just get on with the fucking making of the
thing right like I know that this is a special but I mean it very much relates to the question of his own
authenticity right like right I I have to believe and and this is speculative and at some level
doesn't really matter but this is fucking unbelievably scripted like and and rehearsed
and like meticulous I mean I don't know anything about this guy but my guess is this guy fucking
meticulously rehearses every pause every like you could see his earlier specials because on stage what
he used to do is he would have it where he like I dropped my water bottle like he drops his water
bottle and then over the last week it's like I meant to drop my water bottle you idiot then he
picks it back up and drops it again so he's calling attention to the way to the and that's something
of authentic early in his style but yeah I mean I totally agree because I think even setting those
things up there's a performative nature of it I mean he's fully aware the camera is on he he had
you know the um what's the word I'm looking for I mean essentially he knew that he was putting
that he edited together himself we see that it's edited by Go Burnham like he's very self-aware
that I'm putting this together there's a it's not like you're just sitting in his room as much as he
wants you to feel that way but I think I don't know if it's sincerity in the content but I feel like
it's sincerity in form because I think his intention to make it feel sincere is a sincere intention if
that makes sense but I don't think anywhere throughout the piece there's a level of sincerity because it is
all scripted that's impossible I mean they're really yeah to an extent isn't inherent sincerity in
any kind of art but it's the artifice of sincerity right like it's it's one version of artifice and
that doesn't make it fake either right that's yeah to me that's the important thing and I think that's
what you're getting at is like we tend to want to say either it's fake or it's real and I think the
interesting thing that he's doing with that is say like no no no sincerity needs to be artificized
too right right it needs to be performed also in addition true sincerity is a mass right I think like
look the guy spent what months writing and testing lighting before he started recording anything you
know you see in some of those clips that are sort of like the insincere sincere authenticity of the
thing being made that you can't see but like he's doing the same song over and over and over and over
again right and you know and then like when you see him yeah i breathe too loud yeah and then he beats
himself up for it and you're like that's a trope too right like and you know what i so you use the
language of this preparer yeah exactly exactly and that's what i mean you mentioned masks and irony
mate and that's that was one of the first things that hit me like probably within the
second or third i texted you about it John well i think i texted both of you
about it that you know within but well before the halfway point i was like all right i'm thinking
this through that kind of irony comedy distinction where you know the ironic you know as a kind of
like the meta move it takes you know it meta moves up and then it reflects on the thing that happens
which you know he invites you to think that he's doing over and over and over again except for the the
problem with irony is that it always requires a kind of a surface or a foundation that is the object of
reflection right and then it's the real thing that everything else is just a layer on top of of the
other thing and it presumes that okay like you know you that that irony actually allows you to make the
the serious not serious that's right the authentic inauthentic divide and what i really like about
this is he that he doesn't he he kind of flattens out this the serious non-serious authentic
inauthentic uh relationship a little bit where he's just wearing them as masks and you know you give it
it long enough into the series but not masks that hide a real thing just masks behind masks exactly
closet behind a closet behind the fireplace yes
we'll obviously edit that out because that didn't make that i don't think that made the
the original one my my secret closet but that's it is it is that Nietzschean logic of like proliferation
of masks it's not like there's a real genuine point that you get to behind all of the masks it's
just masks which also doesn't make it fake right it doesn't make it insincere either well i mean
especially because the way he starts off with sort of really trying to reconcile to
pressures on him which is on the one hand the world is up i should probably do something about it
wait also my subject position as a white hetero male kind of positions me as the problem so i do i need
to just shut up now that's boring i got to do something and you know it's that search for i
guess that kind of holy grail search of trying to find the right what is the right thing for me to do
and his response to that seems to be to proliferate a series of engagements all while inhabiting
different tropes different masks that's right he does it's all true that's like the songs it's just a
series of tropes of genres that he does something with each of those genres i mean that is that's his
mo i i agree when you start taking those genres and those tropes and you start inhabiting them then
like unexpected interesting things start to come out of them right like one of my favorites and this is
actually one of the most self-contained but um well it actually happened several times you know like
the very first one about how like you know he's making some content for you right like daddy made
you your content open wall open your mouth open your mouth right and that's sort of the the way that
desire and eroticism sort of mix interestingly with content production and that's sort of like the
corporate machinery but in particular uh i think the song was called problematic and it's the one where he's
reflecting on previous material that that like is not like he he wonders you know if you're going to
hold him accountable and he's trying to self-reflect them this is way out of it but then he
self-reflects on the self-reflection which would think you would think that that's you know the ironic
you know meta move right that that's that's reaching above but what i mean i just thought
that the particular intersection of the erotics of that right like you know it's hot to be held
accountable and the sort of like being you know the beaten into submission with the sort of like
religious like guilt uh you know this is what i deserve with the sort of self-reflective like i am
am i in the clear now am i okay now that i self-reflected and you know i've kind of atoned for my sins
atonement right like and it's it's right that that particular chunk i thought was really interesting
too for exactly that reason it's super erotic right like yeah it's him in a workout like a
sweaty workout video um atoning right getting better right he's a toning for his or asking for the
punishment and it is the sort of erotics of self-punishment like please punish me um so that
i'm getting better because it's the mix of like it's like rocky balboa preparing to fight ivan drago
but it's also, you know, like the the bad girl, like seduction video at the same time that that
made me think of though i mean going back to like the catholic church and like the eroticism of jesus
and sacrifice and it's like all kind of comes into fruition because i feel like there is an inherent
sexuality with being like the sacrificial lamb and that atonement so it's kind of interesting
you know it's not even so much him being a good boy because he's you know i'm i'm really i mean
really it's just the assuming Christ figure which again you know not to be the Bo Burnham scholar here
but if you've listened to a song from God's perspective he has a joke before and he's like
i just want to preface that like you know i don't want my audience to think that i know more than
anyone else now here's a song from God's perspective and it's kind of interesting to see that you know
again it's like the it all kind of comes together yes i mean look there are many ways he could have
done that song right one would be a sort of satire of repentance we can imagine that but he went with
the total erotics and physicality of repentance and in doing so i mean i i agree with you guys like
that it gives it that added sense now i'm not sold on the distinction that you're making Nathaniel
because i also do i do sometimes feel like he's he he remains often remains content with the sort of
pointing out of the ironic distance and the circularity uh Caroline and i were texting about this a little
a little while ago of like you know being the critic but also being self-aware of the problems with being
the critic right and and then he just sort of like abandons he's just like ah fuck it that's just what
it is right like and that that oscillation recurs i'm thinking specifically which a segment that i
loved as well was the um uh the the criticism of the worker exploitation thing where he did this
the the boxes keep proliferating right where he says i'm going to do the critical the critical review
moment and um so and this is and this to me when i first watched it i instantly thought of Nate's
interest in Hegelian self-awareness right like that that to me was a segment that was perfect on
here's what self-awareness looks like okay i did my thing right now i'm going to explain it to you
and then explaining it to you i'm going to explain like oh there's this long history of worker
exploitations but we haven't done it for the 21st century right we we have it for coal mines like
you load 16 tons and what do you get like there's a whole history of that that's right of the worker
exploitation but we don't have it for the the information economy and so i took the genre of
that song and i plugged in what what it's like the uh the unpaid intern the unpaid intern uh story
which by the way you were right Caroline were very recently well i was i was thankfully a paid
intern though i have taken unpaid internships in the past and i was very lucky but again like also the
irony is when you work for a huge company um that i'm not going to name drop i mean people could you
you know track it back i mean you know they do treat you well for that reason but most like most
of my friends the entertainment industry you know p i mean pas depends but for the most part you're
not being paid for the work that you're doing and like but that's a part of it because in order and
of course it all comes back to privilege which he obviously touches on where it's like you know if
you don't have the financial stability to have an unpaid internship because that is work that's
taking you away from hours that you could work doing a regular job yeah that's right like i mean you
have i mean there's just no way that you could possibly get a position if you don't have any
industry experience but to get that you need free labor um and that's like so blatantly exploited
sometimes you have to pay for the internship not only is it unpaid you have to pay thousands of
dollars to even participate well that's not true you get paid in experience
but that's the line and connection but i mean but i mean so so but so he uses i mean that's to me the
interesting thing is he links it to this genre this musical genre from 50 years ago of the sort of worker
exploitation and he upstates it for the information economy but he doesn't just do that because that
would be funny right that would be comedic in its conventional sense he then takes that next move
and says oh i'm gonna teach you what i just did right like and that's the first move and then the
second move he keeps it running and he's like oh now i see myself teaching you what i just did and now
i see myself seeing myself teaching you what i just did so it just all it just amplifies that self-reflection
until it gets to the point and and this is the way that it ends is just stop right just just stop now
and that to me that's that that's the kind of interesting dynamic because i feel like
The whole thing is that it is this whole playing out of a sort of a circumstance and the self-awareness
of one's imbrication in the circumstance even as one's created like a critique and one's
imbrication in the critique and everything that he's doing keeps, you know, uh, keeps returning to that
motif, and it and it never uh in a sense sort of um it does feel paralyzing because it's like
it's not because he doesn't provide a solution he just seems to be so hung up on that problem
and the recurrence of of that problem and that's where to me uh Nathaniel wants to read him more
positively as saying actually what he's pointing out is that there isn't a depth relation between the
critique and the self-awareness of critique such that it's this constant oscillation going nowhere
right, the the circle, instead it's just a series of different encounters that occur which is i mean
but i i'm not sold i mean i i get that i think that's a more interesting read but i feel like he
is actually more interested in staying trapped in self self-awareness self-aware neuroses right and
that becomes and that's to me exactly why that mental health portion of the last 20 minutes is a problem
is because it's sort of saying you do you do cultural critique self-aware enough you're going to lose your
mind right right i mean look i think if we're going to think about like what he's trying to do and and
think in terms of intention and design here that that very well may be right i mean like even i'm still
on defense because he all he does the irony movie does it you know like a number of times but definitely
not in everyone not even every other one right so like i mean if you're gonna and he he plays with
the same tropes you know a number of times other other tropes other than the irony trope you know a
number of times and it's just that you know we tend to call irony one of the master tropes
but you know i think he plays with other tropes as well if you didn't think about is the the master trope
but i where it really kind of solidified it for me was i think it was in the second half and it was as
it was turning toward his mental health and it was as he was self-reflecting and it was about how he
um you'd already talked about self-dissociation uh or total dissociation and then this one he's like
i think the line was something to the effect of you know i i googled um derealization and didn't
like what i found which was one of the few times i paused it like okay i'm gonna google derealization
as well except i liked what i found because i mean it is effectively you know the the inability to
sort of ground reality and the real and sort of like taking especially the the digital virtual real
divide and looking at does that you know the the world in these sort of um uh virtual tropological
figures and but that's all the real is all the real is are are tropological figures that have calcified
in a particular kind of of way and he is experimenting with those with those tropes and you know he has
another one kind of in line with um you know worker exploitation and he talks about the real the the
tactile you know physical universe as a coal mine that you go to yeah you you dive down get your material
bring it back to the surface and then play it out and the most constant thing that i think that he does
are take particularly take recognizable internet tropes like the reaction video the twitch live stream the
instagram the like a number of these tick tock like a number of these these things and then he puts
them in conversation he puts them in alliances that we don't that they don't tend to get put into
like what happens when the reaction becomes the reaction becomes the reaction to the reaction or what
happens when the twitch live streaming is you know watching yourself in the live cinema gaming i yeah
congratulations you cried four times i wish they wouldn't make the hint so obvious right and he's
like really inhabiting like he sounds like a twitch gamer he sounds like a no i agree right but he sounds
like the social media brand consultant but much like the bob odenkirk you know um david cross uh um you know the
show things that it always is pushing those tropes to a point where if the trope feels a bit
unrecognizable to itself it's sort of like mutated into something else because it's weirdly remained
faithful to the thing that's that's a better i mean i gotta be honest with you i like your reading better
than mine like i really do because really because for instance to me like his opening question why joke
about this or what can you joke about this and and given his given you know white guy's status right
like i i sort of felt like he just kind of throws his hands up and like well i don't fucking know
as opposed to your your reading would say actually you make a fucking video like he proceeded to do for
the next 85 minutes which is which is to say all you can do is operate in this ambiguous space where you
are participating in the thing that you're creating that's the only option right like you're part of the
Part of the depression, part of the problem, yeah, the yeah, the the depression, the sincerity, the crying
The everything where you feel like you're breaking through to the authentic, they're just other tropes
that he's deploying, which doesn't make them, as you said, doesn't make them fake, doesn't put them
doesn't mean that they're the same thing as a silly tropes or whatever else, right? They can still
be, you know, quite heavy hitting, but you know, he's, he, these are all tropes that he's mobilizing and like to
me that, as you said, the special, the movie itself is the response to that more fundamental question
is like, I'm stuck inside for a year, I'm gonna make this thing and you know I'm gonna like deal with
like heavy, depressing, you know, I want to put a bullet in my head shit, right? And I'm gonna do with the
crazy ass techno music and, you know, pretend to be a Twitch streamer for a little bit and it's not just
silly, it's not just folly, I, I'm kind of losing my mind, but it's also creating a livable interesting
space for me that that's a much better because then then the sort of self-reflexivity instead of
just oscillating between surface and depth, surface and depth becomes serial, right? It becomes serialized
and it's just like, okay, here's the next thing and the next thing and the next segment and the next
segment and it actually would go a long way to explaining the staccato quality, right? Like it's
the constant stop and start is the sort of thinking that you're getting to a depth uh level or a height
of transcendence, a space of purity of some kind outside of like standing now outside of the comedic
i can reflect on what the role of the comedic is, you know, or what the role of the white guy, it's like
that's not an option, right? It's there is no so so that's to me, that's a much more interesting point
which is that it's showing you the necessary implication of one's actions in the very thing
that one is critiquing, and that that's not a problem, that's not like a failure, that's just the case
like there's no space accesses a meta meta reflective height or an authentic real that grounds anything
else, and that's by the way what most i think i think that um Nanette does that I think that Dave
Chappelle does that I think I don't think that the Bob Odenkirk, you know, David Cross stuff does that
but Bojack Horseman does that, I think, right? I mean, you know, I think a lot, especially can't
like stand-up comedy specials, you know, like I mean comedy is for all of its sort of like perverse
like subversive potential I tend to find it to have as a genre usually a very conservative
force where it it takes the outlier and it makes yeah it's it makes fun yeah it takes the outlier and
it makes fun of the thing and pulls back to a common senseness, right? I think John Stewart is an
excellent example of that, right? And and frankly, um, uh, Stephen Colbert when he was doing the Colbert Report
except for he inhabited the ridiculous side of it in order to give you glimpses of the common sense
thing that he would like you to move toward, you know? I think that's a very I like that that's better
than mine. I still am going to have a hard time with the move to the personal though because it just
feels like, you know, and if there had been one additional segment that returned to a cultural
critique moment, like if if for instance the the white woman instagram sketch had been the final sketch
instead of embedded early on, right? It would have been like, okay, going through this sort of personal
mental deterioration comes out it's like, okay, I'm gonna, I'm I'm just gonna continue to serially
produce my problematic and and uh difficult uh critiques of social structures that I'm participating
in even as I'm critiquing them, right? Like I'm making a fucking video that's going to go out on Netflix
Netflix while I'm critiquing internet culture, right? And that's but that's the only way that's not
the difference is that's not paralyzed, that doesn't have to be paralyzing, it's only paralyzing if you see it
in that surface surface depth relation, it's like no that's the only thing you can do, you know? I was
just going to add too though it is interesting coming back to our question of like whether or not
it's really a comedy because John your comment about you know it doesn't feel right that it goes it
devolves from you know the critical cultural to the personal because it's more linear and we're so used
to the comedy I mean, you know, comedy comes in threes and of course the most impressive thing a stand-up
comic can do is they you know call back to something earlier in the set and it's this big moment
because we all remembered it, um, but I think what's really interesting though with Bo Burnham and
honestly kind of like the antithesis of A Net because I know what might have been A Net or it could
have been another special by Hannah Gadsby where she mentions um I mean to be honest I was uh
drinking a little bit when I watched the two of them because I needed to needed to kind of you know
Ease my nerves with that but where she I don't again I don't remember which one it was specifically
But she outlined exactly what she was going to do like in in pretty much like shocking and then
At the end she actually does it and the whole time you're like oh my God she did it and she even like
You know but in the opposite you know you don't really know what he's going to do but you do to
An extent you got these motifs and you got these themes but it's interesting because you know if what
We consider a comedy and I know I'm just kind of like going against what I initially had said where
It's you know it's still comedy but it's a different kind um you know at the very you know it's it's a
Linear d evolution of this and there really isn't a conclusive ending um and I kind of lost my train
Of thought as I was saying it probably but there isn't there isn't I mean but there isn't a conclusive
Ending and he obviously does that quite intentionally right like he he leaves and then he's trapped
Outside but then he's actually watching himself being trapped outside and there's a little bit of
A smirk at the end that of course is the Mona Lisa move right like we could interpret that in in
Multiple different ways and we get that that you know and then I whatever he liked it he's like
I'm so depressed I'm sort of but that was fucking funny
Right it's fucking funny that when he finally gets out of the house he's now locked down
The sort of the cruelty humor right like yeah I mean it can be he's funny or you know that that's
Sort of but but more but more to like the the the want to turn this into a project of living is like
After that's right I mean after spending what 20 minutes of a kind of turning more to the personal
More to the depressive and then the last thing he does is smile it's like I did all this this is
This is fucking funny it also comes back though and this is kind of tapping onto the thought that
I was trying to finish but then I lost my train of thought but I'm kind of halfway hopping back on
Is like it's almost as if like it's the and I say fruition a lot of his career but the fruition
Of the set in and of itself because there's that line I believe in Problematic where he says exactly
He's like you know why or maybe it is probably I don't know which one it is but he says that like
Why is it that white people always feel the need to look at you know any kind of social justice issue
As a personal actualization self-actualization that was Mr. Sacco Mr. Sacco said that exactly
And that's exactly what he does though is because he takes all these cultural problems and at the
Very end of the set it's all about bo and self-actualization exactly and that's kind of the end of
It and that's how it ends and it's you know he's demonstrating like what he'd put out so I guess in
Some ways he does kind of call back to it not necessarily maybe intentionally I don't really
Know um but it's less of a a comedic special more of just like the unraveling of a person
And not in a in a way that it's like oh this is how I unraveled but again back to that performative
Nature of like this is how we unravel societies we start with critique and we start with like this
Kind of lighter still dark comedy and at the very end we're just in this massive hole that comes back
To like well how do I fit into this how does this affect me because we're all just a bunch of
Narcissists and then of course at the very end that little wink of like and most importantly how
Am I going to perform this on social media how am I going to dig up this content from my real life
And put it into the digital space which is honestly in a way more real and more relevant than what we
Actually exist in well like there are I mean there are a number of ways but let's say there are two ways
Of of mobilizing tropes right the the one is in that Hannah Gadsby kind of way where the way that
She's describing to her audience is like look all comedians work through tropes we work through these
Structures we minute like we're able to build tension and then allow for release and then you know really
Good ones they hide how they're doing it's the kind of spread to tura thing where you know it just seems so
Effortless that you know this thing that I'm doing in the third act calls back to something in the first
Act and changes it a little bit but you know it's like but now everything is complete right and it
Looked effortless I dropped the bottle right at the right time and then I let everyone know that I and
Then Hannah Gadsby tells you and I knew it and I'm showing you how I'm doing it and you still think
It's incredible right I don't I don't see Burnham doing that over the in in the macro in in the in
The sort of like stages and sets I I see him wearing the tropes on their sleeves right I mean because of
The sort of more interesting reading I think right that like the the the kind of um satiristic but
Again, not in that sort of like heights level is like I'm going, I'm going to wear, you know, the genre that
that I am sort of inhabiting honestly and then it's going to go in in kind of weird ways and I'm not
going to give you a sense it's sort of an interesting distinction you make though because the the
performance of effortlessness is kind of key to most live comedy like with someone like Chapelle
he's known for being able to come into a room not be prepared at all and make everybody falling out of
their seat for an hour with brand new material you know and this was like effortful there was nothing
effortless about this special it was calling attention to the process again and again how much
work he was putting into it how many iterations of every sketch you know he did so it's like that the
performance of putting effort into comedy is something you don't traditionally see and i think that uh
changes the obviously the viewing experience as well yeah that that's kind of yeah i totally agree yeah
you know because obviously Chapelle doesn't come in unprepared it doesn't just throw out you know
totally it was like everything has been meticulously workshopped right right right yeah but you it feels
that way yeah it's the car it's the it's the this did Chapelle was the figure of spread to tour
exactly and this special did feel like and it packaged itself like this as almost like a survival
kit for for Bo Burnham like he had to do this this was what like propelled him through that year
year and a half however long he was alone he had to make something and this is what he happened to
be able to make during that time which it was it's extremely impressive i mean you guys are talking
through like different theoretical um lines that you could kind of pull out of Burnham i don't think i
really had much of a reading of it in that sense i was more attuned to the the composition of the
thing i was more just impressed with like like for example the uh the when he does the reaction video
and then the the reaction on the reaction video and it keeps going to infinity i wasn't really like i was
like okay the content of that is interesting but what's more interesting is like how did he actually make
that which it must have taken so much time to to detail and orient those videos on top of each other
and he does that in multiple times where he like that's so funny because i never thought of that at
all for me i instantly the moment it came up i'm like even when he was in the first window i remember
watching it even before the second window came up i was like oh this will be perfect for Nate on
self-reflexivity right yeah i didn't i don't know i mean i get what you're saying like it's a it's a
sufficiently intellectual and it brands itself as an intellectual comedy special right it's also a
production yeah i found it the composition of the thing was what i kept because i make music too and
i was like man he is taking a lot of time to make all these songs all the transitions all the cutting
and pasting the callbacks you know and so on i don't know if it's a relevant thought on that but
what i i had i mean there was a part of me from a production element that i thought that too but more
so from a personal and a coveted perspective feeling like a real piece of shit because i'm like wow what
did i do during this time like i sat around and i went on you know i had a couple of white claws and
watched The Shining with some friends and yet at the same time the irony too is that we're watching
someone go through a breakdown and it's not a pleasurable experience to watch him and these
uncomfortable silences and yet there was a strange envy in the level of quality that this breakdown
was because it's not like we're watching him on an iPhone just kind of like you know being a dick
like it's like the the fact that it's so intelligent and so well produced for being as heavy as it is
well a real yeah a real breakdown doesn't end up on Netflix so you know he managed the breakdown
sufficiently through this composition process you know but that's the point like i had zero investment
about whether or not the the breakdown is real or not like i mean i again like very early on yeah it
kind of just signaled to me right that this is you know everything in here is artifice and that and so
remaining in in in that in that sphere right um which isn't to say that you know he wasn't yeah which
isn't to say that he didn't wasn't like having serious mental trouble just that the therapy was
doing this thing right you can look i mean here's at the level of identification which i mean you know
on one level who gives a fuck about our abilities to identify with various things but that's what we
did guys we made a podcast during pandemic like that's we did we i mean look we don't have nearly the
production value we don't have the content and the viewership and we don't but that's what we did and
it was the same motivation remember like a you know a little over a year ago roughly about now this is
About the year anniversary, we're like, hey, let's just fucking do something, right? It points to the
importance of having a project, especially when you're isolated. I mean, to be able to be on your own
and have any kind of repose or comfort day to day, you have to have something to do, something that's
driving you project that's like it takes hours and hours each day, and a lot of people don't have
that Bo Burnham is lucky enough that he has the the technical skills, the uh, the comedic skills to be
able to work on, most people wouldn't even know how to start to work on something like that including
me. I like the video, I mean, I i it's beyond my technical capabilities, you know, really, but but
for me, like, we we could do this. Writing takes just Microsoft Word, and that can occupy enough of your
time so, you know, you need to have a that's the importance post-Covid even people need to find
projects, not just like the day job or whatever. Like, if you're on your own, you need to have something to
do and and within the context of those projects wrestling with the necessarily like ethical
ambiguity of participating in any way. Like, okay, you're gonna, you're gonna do cultural critique,
well who what am I, I'm you know, a middle-aged straight white guy gonna do cultural critique
well that doesn't mean you shouldn't do cultural critique. That's one of the things that he considers
is like, well maybe I should just shut the fuck up and he's like, nope, gonna keep going, um, right
on board, you know, it's like, it's not don't do it, it's you can only do it and simultaneously recognize
the impossibility of the purity of your position, right? Like, um, so yeah, you still speak from a position
and people are going to respond and they're going to say whatever they want to say. That's his whole
the whole problematic thing is like you're bracketing the the erotics of the desire the content of
it is is about like, look, I said a bunch of shit when I was younger that I didn't really mean. I
mean it wasn't illegal but it was pretty bad and it was thoughtless, and what does one do with that? I
mean it raises to me that whole kind of what's called cancel culture question, right? Like, uh, and
frankly for me, I mean that was one of the questions that I wanted to put to you guys because that
cancel culture is a term that comes up and I don't really know what it means, right? Like, I i mean in
fact it seemed to me that it kind of came up when it became a conservative critique against
like the term itself came up when it became a conservative critique against what it perceived
as liberals who were who were pursuing this cancel culture, so I don't really know because in this
case it's like what would cause us to cancel him or whatever would be previous videos that he's made
like his work, but it seems to me like a lot of cancel culture is about the extra work biographies
of people like not things that they do in their movies or in their comedy shows but things that they
do out you know in their life outside of the comedy, yes and no because I will say cancel culture has
devolved, I think most prominently cancel culture more so took off, I would argue with the me too movement
because cancel culture kind of started as holding people accountable who weren't previously held
accountable for things because they had this kind of absurd power and now it's kind of devolved to
this point of canceling someone for to some extent just being I mean, again, like I look at it as you know
a person should be quote unquote, I mean I don't like using the word canceled, but held accountable for
doing something that would get you fired from any other job, like if you were to assault someone if you
were blatantly racist etc. and now it's kind of getting to this point where it's not a matter of being
canceled for having those qualities or doing things that kind of toe the line of breaking the law or
things that would get you fired but purely just not being a good person, we don't like you, yeah
exactly, which comes back to this whole weird ideology where it's like, you know, why do we care so much
about artists to the point that they have to be a good person outside of not being, you know, a criminal
or like a horrible, you know, irate people kind of person but just uh, you know, they're yeah, they have
some shitty takes on things and like why do we take these artists so seriously and hold them to the
standard that they have to be perfect when a this is a cliche thought we are clearly not. I mean
my answer to that, you know, reason of why we are that way is I think a lot of his social medium being
you know, intertwined with your personal and your professional life so much so that your characters
that you perform are reflective on you and I think especially as a comedian it's not like like
yes Bo Burnham is playing a character as Bo Burnham the comedian but it's still his name
it's still his image so coming back to like him whether or not you know he's worthy of being
canceled if that was kind of the question, it's an interesting one because everyone looks for an
apology with cancellations, but at the same time what does that really do, you know, like
what is a recognition of those things, especially if you can tell this person self-aware enough, and
i don't really know the answer to that. i mean Nathaniel just did the gesture right, it's the self
flagellation of, yeah right, like, yeah i'm guilty, i'm not worthy, but but it's that i'm guilty, i'm not
worthy thing that makes the eye i think in this and there's the there's the particular line in that
that problematic one that i think works really well to destabilize the meta-reflective thing
where you know first he talks about uh uh the the wearing the aladdin costume, then he's like
you know, i i then he reflects on it, it's like i didn't darken my skin but it still feels wrong
you know i was a kid but i've grown up, and then he reflects on the reflection and he's like
i i i self-reflection doesn't buy you out of anything my actions are my own and that would
that that pose that would that could be a space where he reaches the sort of meta-reflective
heights of you know the proper awareness of something right except that it's embedded with this entire
song about being held accountable and the guilt erotic relationship that is getting questioned at the
core right so yeah so there there is that kind of move back to the the the sort of the the um
the it's just the endless circle of critique self-awareness except you don't come back to it
the same like so what i think that you know the the dominant tension is between accountability and
eroticism right but i think what that lying sort of and like um uh uh adds to the mix is sovereignty as
well as a sense of the eye as a persistent object that even is capable of being held accountable what
was i mean think from from the nation perspective what would it even mean to say that the eye of 17
you know wearing the aladdin costume and the eye is accountable at age 30. yeah what they're not even
the same person which by the way is terrifying to think i'm not the same person i was you know at 17
at a at a kind of an ontological level right but part of what's hot what part of what happens with so
with you know what let's call it like very loosely the post-modern movement especially in in art where
the um where the the line between character and actor you know that raise or think about like ryan
reynolds and deadpool or something like that he makes a joke about that deadpool i know self-awareness
i like that yeah right which for him is sort of like weak sauce that it is you know that's right
right it was a great you know i mean as much as i love deadpool and ryan reynolds but ryan reynolds
is the iron that's right he is yes and he's like that's like but that's that's actually producing
the real ryan ryan reynolds right because we know you're wearing a mask and even when you're
meta-reflecting on wearing the mask that's right you know that there's something in there true or
real true right and i think what he's doing and well i mean i don't care i don't know the he i don't
even know what i mean to say there is a he that's doing the thing in this context but what's happening
in that song is that like the very desire there's there's an erotics to the desire for an eye which
is pretty essentially linked to punishment punishment right yeah i must i mean i must go i must be
punished the only thing yes spank me so i can be a real boy not so i can be a good boy i want to be
a real boy the only thing kind of funny about that song and part of the part of the special to me is
that Bo Burnham is like one of the least offensive least controversial comics that i can think of
at least of some of the like the more popular comedians like people like Jeselnik or like there's
this whole movement Tim Dyln there's these people that are saying things that should get them
canceled you know what i mean Bo Burnham is not has not as far as i know said anything that would get
him canceled besides just being a white straight male which i guess makes you vulnerable i guess to
some extent in this context i just feel like he's not problematic you know like the the comedy is not
problematic at all what what well what is the like i know nothing right like in terms of what is i mean
what is his story like has he you you said Caroline in one of your comments to me that that he is sort
of of he exists on this he's both been canceled and not canceled maybe depending on who you ask i mean
what i don't know anything about well i mean again the things that again he has been canceled for
because you know like you can kind of imagine he's always been a very self-aware artist and i actually
saw this article that you know when he first came out and was like you know in the spotlight saying that
he's like it was called like pubescent comedy music writing and it is both like uh like abhorrent and
entertaining in a weird folksy way and that's kind of always been his brand and he's always owned that
um but in the sense that he's been canceled it's like they're more recently I guess like, you know
with the Gen Z audience like for instance like white women's Instagram it's like is he making fun of
women or like then there was another, you know, part where it's like well no like he's like saying that
like the Instagram is the only sphere that people can express themselves and I'm jealous of women for
not having that I mean I don't think that was really it at all I don't really know exactly what it is
but I don't even think it was that deep in a way and also like who gives a shit uh to be honest
because it's like yeah I don't know I think sorry I again I'm I mean to me it's just yeah that I I like
that sketch uh to me the whole thing was a satire about the cliched quality of individuality
well yeah well also just social media being everybody has like you know this is like the
the standard this is who I am this is like everyone else here I'm going to perform both
lyrically and visually the tropes of you know and you see the background of it genre but making that
sorry uh but just real quick making that particular sketch palatable to a woke or progressive audience
is the white if he if it was just women's Instagram you could never make that sketch you would never be
able to sell that but putting the what qualifying it is white women yeah you're allowed to make fun of
white women women know black people know any other ethnicity or creed or whatever you're not allowed
to target people but white women are still an allowable uh target in this because you have the Karens I
mean you have like you know and again obviously the existence of that category is exactly the
thing he's talking about exactly that that category emerges that in a historical moment it's like okay
this is still a group that you're allowed to target and give a a degrading name to even if the name is
you know a proper name there's also been you know discussion too on like not even necessarily
cancellation in the sense that I guess when I say Boburnham's been canceled and not canceled that the K I
wouldn't even consider them genuine genuine cancellation because what I consider a person
to be canceled is you like I said someone who's being held accountable for something they should
have been held accountable a long time yeah and most people are canceling him on his content but just
because something's offensive does that mean it should be canceled because on one hand and again there's
different levels of it you know for instance if someone to use the N-word like yeah they that's you know
pretty fucked up but that's also I mean because to me again and maybe I'm holding on to an antiquated
distinction here is that you know when I think of the sort of emergence of the Me Too it was you know
the Woody Woody Allen like it was it was things people had done outside of their art yeah like in
their personal lives that were abhorrent right and reprehensible but it wasn't their art that was
and their art was obviously impacted by that but it wasn't like people were saying your movie was
offensive or your you know whatever after the fact after the fact right after the fact yeah right yeah
so it was it was extra extra textual you might say right like and it was yeah in a sense it was
this kind of collapsing of the whole personal and professional which is he's doing right he goes
from becoming a brand personal right like yeah well yeah I mean even looking at artists too like you
said it's all retrospective because like you know you look at Roman Polanski and that's Roman
Polanski but now you know a lot of his content to an extent I wouldn't say is being canceled but
it's more heavily critiqued knowing who he is versus a Quentin Tarantino who isn't technically
canceled has some pretty creepy you know weird angles absolutely and we're like well that's fine
but you know when we find out like you know he pulls an Armie Hammer and he's eating them and like
assaulting girls and eating feet it's like well that's a different story so it it is definitely
like in the conversation yeah I mean hey we don't know I mean I don't want to predict anything
um but yeah but what you're talking about is sort of like someone doing jokes in their you know in
their routine or in their show or whatever that is offensive which is to me a different kind of
question and and that's the thing but I do think that that it has evolved though where as like I said
initially it was like it's now at the point that both your content and your person because they can't
be extricated anymore given social media and kind of this weird influencer celebrity culture that now it
doesn't matter whether it's your content or whether it's your person now I mean again it's all varies
depending on what you've done or if it's more personal or more content oriented but like for
Whatever reasons and I don't say I even agree with them, but there is now in conversations at least a
basis to be canceled if your content is at a certain level of being offensive, which I just think is really
interesting, especially in the comedic sphere when like what we said, you know, in the beginning of the
conversation, like the point of comedy is trying to give you that almost a guilty space that you can
laugh at something because you're like, oh, like, it's a joke, it's fine, like I if I were to talk about
this, you know, in a serious tone, you know, all bets are on the table, so I have to assume that you know
in comedy I can laugh and I won't be canceled for actually another interesting Bo Burnham bit is where
he gets the audience to say the n-word and the way that he does it, which actually this is also another
reason he got canceled was he said like chips go good with like crackers and then he was like early
he said when I say peanut, like peanut butter, and then he goes vin and people say the n-word, but again it
was like, and then he turns on the lights and he goes, all right, you guys are all like canceled, this
was like, I think in 2016, he's like, all right, you guys are all canceled, call the cops, show the cameras
like your grandchildren are going to know your bigots, you know, and like, and in a way it was like on one
hand there was just the level of getting the audience to say the n-word, on the other hand it was like
critiquing cancel culture was almost a cancellation because it's like, oh, so you're making fun of the
genuine reasons people have had been to cancel and you're saying now that cancel culture is just you can
make anybody do it, anyone can be canceled, but also there is kind of some truth to that to an extent
you know, again, it's it's like talking in circles, but I mean there is an interesting way in which and
I'm thinking like in the small terrain of our world of literary studies let's say in which authorial
intention has been at least theoretically a kind of problem for 40 years um in the sense of, you know, a
lot of folks that I would include myself in this are like, look, the author's biography is kind of
irrelevant, like it doesn't matter very much unless what you're trying to do is understand the work
but for the most part we're not trying to understand the work like what we're doing now we're not trying
to understand, you know, start to finish every dimension of this thing um if we are like using
some points and riffing off of them about, you know, whatever it is that we're we're talking about, but
so for the most part there's this way in which the sort of author author's biography has become um
I don't know, like maybe less conceptually sophisticated way of approaching literary studies
plenty of people still do it so it's not like it's gone away, but in the larger culture it's like we've
author like authorial intention has become the yeah like in other words, you know, one might have
a great movie or a great book or a great whatever but we want to know who the person was, we want to
know like could you even have a Thomas Pynchon today right like a yeah someone who writes in
total anonymity recluse yeah I mean even it's funny you mentioned that because one of my English classes
in college we had a similar discussion of like with Chaucer I mean well obviously he might have been but
like you know there's the whole thing where whether or not Chaucer raped people and it's like but also
you know and talk about today does that matter when reading Chaucer should it matter should we talk
about it and it's it's a really interesting perspective on like especially like in history like we've never
cared more about an author and they're tied to the work I mean I always look up a director after
I watch the film especially when it's something about women I'm like did a woman director you
know and sometimes I can tell but with that being said I think this conversation is really interesting
because we're not just critiquing his art in the sense that like oh he made this and we're looking
at him as a person but in a sense to talk about it you have to talk about him because it he makes
it so personal I mean he sort of way yeah in a way he invites it but I think part of the thing is that
that's the sort of social media world right like yeah the dissociation of like my professional content
what I put out there in my sort of theory world and my books and articles and podcasts or whatever
can't be separated from my interaction with my neighbors
yeah I mean a lot of it is like about the pretending to be good that everybody does both
on the internet the whole corporate world like I I don't watch a lot of commercials except when I'm
watching the NBA Finals, you know, which is on right now and all commercials are so sinister, right? because
they perform sincerity, right? so like Starbucks pretends to be for the people or you know whatever
like Wheat Thins cares about black people and it's like it's it's completely like my disease, right
though yeah yeah wheat thins join join our effort against lyme disease which i had last year so i
i thought that sketch that sketch was good about yourself? yeah, it was so fun. there was a whole joke
about how every uh there was a picture it's like literally the day like a minute after like the last
day of pride had passed you see all the company's logos change back from the rainbow, which well that's
what happened last year. i mean, so in canada that or at least in halifax that happened last year and
there was so much backlash yeah, now like people put up the rainbow and it stays right? but like i mean
what you would on the one hand you think wonderful everyone's now even woker it was like no now you
just perma thingified pride, right? it's a permanent yeah, you made it another consumer product it's like
yeah exactly, like buy our absolute vodka because it's rainbow now, like i mean you're using civil
rights to sell stuff yeah, yeah. i mean, or i love of course which beau burnham even gets into is the
whole you know just performance activism of like during black lives matter i mean like every person
on my feed even myself included for a little while until i just stopped posting simply because it was
like you know there was even posting i see you if you're not posting and then you're like oh god
like now i have to post because my friends noticed me so then i would start posting and i got to this
point where i'm like okay but like i'm donating on my own like i'm you know doing my own thing why do i
care if other people know that if i'm you know feel fine about myself and it comes back to this
weird little like everyone must know that like i'm so woke and it's like but that's not helping
anybody that's not doing anything and it's like and if anything you're still selling you're like the
corporation because you're just selling your own image of yourself like look at me like i'm the best
brand can i just to jump in on that question there you are i'm back sorry i had to switch to switch
devices but to but but i think it's important that we hold on to the same stuff that we were talking
about in terms of the ambiguity of the position when it comes to corporate relationship to social
issues as well right like because it's very easy to say what i i just came in right at the end there
but it's very easy to say like the kind of thing that i'm hearing you guys saying which is like
corporations are really just about profit and therefore they're not being sincere or genuine in their
commitment to uh to social issues because social issues are finally about you know just a way of
branding themselves that's the the branding thing but i think that if we're going to do that for that
sort of personal social and the question of comedy we should do it for corporations as well which is to
say like yeah the corporation the corporate america is not it's not just a question of like they're
cynically participating in social orders in order to increase brand awareness in order to sell more
products it's like but that's that's what all social action is is this ambiguous or impure relationship
to the political you know and so therefore why would the why would corporations be any more uh um bad
guys like you know then then uh bo burnham is for doing self-aware comedy you know yeah look i like
look i i do agree to the extent that it doesn't mean they're good guys either you have to hold on to that
sense everybody's the bad guy i mean at some level start start plugging rainbows into corporations and
you know despite the fact that they're engineered to increase private profit margins they might also
do other things as well right exactly right i i i i totally agree with that and that's you know there
might be and i mean my general take is like we live in a moment of capitalism in which corporate activity
is the only way to make anything happen like anything in terms of social impact you have to have billionaires
pissed off because you and me like the best we can do is is work to generate anger by billionaires
that's it that's the best that we can do and once the billionaires get pissed off then things might
things actually begin to happen right but yeah no it's well i was gonna yeah say too i mean because
it's like on the flip side well if they did absolutely nothing you know not only is that
a not helping anyone but it's like well now the people who well and again but it also kind of comes
back to you know again obviously a lot of companies it makes sense why they do like for instance i didn't
know this uh berella it's that pasta brand apparently with like made some racist remarks back in the day
they're apparently they were racist so it's like in that sense it's like oh hello dog um you know it's
necessary for them to to put something out there to redeem themselves and you know make those people
those consumers on one hand aware that like hey like we're better now we're not the the assholes that
were running the company before but of course be of course to like you know sell pasta um but that
Being said, it's like, but that cycle kind of, you know, it didn't really start from, like, an apologist
perspective. It was obviously profit, that's right, and that matters, and we're accustomed to it, but if they
weren't and now because that we are accustomed to that mode of activism by branding yourself in such a
way to say, like, I'm with you, if they were to do it, then the flip side would be, well, now they're just
you know homophobic, now they're just racist, the the basic irony I'll let you go after this Nathaniel
sorry, like, so the the definition of being woke basically is attending to systemic structures that
have oppressed people. It's like basically paying attention to that and somehow trying to change that
the the really flat basic irony about corporations trying to be woke is that they profit and benefit almost
exclusively on exploitation, the exploitation of labor, and so if they're trying to make a stand on a social
issue which is usually about some version of exploitation and trying to remedy that, they are
doing that every day all day, you know, that's the point, but that's the point is the necessary impurity
right, like in other words, so I'm I'm uh exercising this kind of exploitation and I'm also improving this
other kind over here, right, like what makes what makes Bo more interesting than a Starbucks commercial
is that he's paying at least some attention to that tension. A corporation is not. Yeah, that like a you
know Starbucks commercial is just I we're woke. There's no like reflecting on what it the attempt to be
woke in the face of these circumstances and the problems with the fact, you know, like how you grow your
beans and all that sort of, although they do in terms of the bean growing, sure, but like I got that but but
that's where I go like what is the value of that self-awareness? Like I wonder about the value or or um
why do we attribute so much value to the fact that Bo Burnham is self-aware of it if self-awareness
ends up just being that sort of circle that doesn't go anywhere, right, like it just becomes a sort of
self-defeating circle as as I was reading you know this earlier on before Nathaniel gave a more
interesting reading of it, right, um, because in that case it's just like it's the same thing with a
corporate question as well, and and at least to me that's the upshot of what he's doing really well
is he's posing the impossibility of purity, that there is no not for the individual on the personal
level, mental health wise, for the social criticism level, for the corporate level, right, like that there is
this the impossibility of purity. So I mean one of the upshots of that is it's just too easy to tell
people that they're hypocritical because literally everyone is. There is no possibility of being
pure righteousness and you know or even like a really good person. It's just not possible, like
in order for anyone to hear you, right, you have to get involved with mechanisms of exploitation,
that's the game, and that is that is the academic question: how do you write Marxist philosophy
right from an institution that's paying you uh, you know, X amount of dollars, right, like that is
and I have never experienced that as a trauma I'm like really easily
like quite comfortably, right, like um, but I but it's precisely because I have always at some level
never believed that one had to exist in a position of purity and that to me is actually
more of the danger of the branding thing is that the premise is that you're supposed to have a
a consistent righteous self from which to act and it's like none of us do, right, like that's exactly
what I want to get when I want to get to especially with the self-reflection stuff is that like if you
think of self-reflection and and then it's more traditional sense then there is a self that is
consistent, you know, that that can be reflected upon and I mean going back to that problematic video that
that self becomes something that can you know obtain the property of guilt, blame, praise, good, bad, whatever
else it is, and we were talking about sort of like you know we were sort of talking around you know the
the sort of the function of authorial intention and authorial biography and I was thinking of you know
you know Foucault's essay What Is an Author? where he's like he's thinking about the authorial name as
an index for gathering a bunch of other stuff and you know especially when he's talking about the sort
of the historical emergence of of the author as sort of it functions politically, economically, socially, and
religiously is what it effectively does is is gathers actions and allows actions and texts in particular
to be um are coordinated with punishable bodies. It made me think of your interest in the punishment
because like that is that is one of his claims there is that texts began to have authors when people
began to be punished for the things that were written for the heretical you know subversive in the 15th
century exactly to like you know the Christ imagery of it all is like you know finding a scapegoat you
Know because it's so easy to push blame and like him embodying this, like, oh, I'm, I'm carrying the weight
of white men in a sense, which also is kind of like, you know, again hypocritical and ironic in
of itself is to place, you know, the whole sins of one community on the representative of it and also
yeah, exactly, yeah, um, but yeah, so it's so interesting that it's like as a Jesus figure, like carrying on
this it's like and that's exactly what you know we expect or what we want to do is to say like, oh
well it's it's the corporation, oh, or it's Bo Burnum, you know, like in in thinking through this I feel
like we're glossing Nietzsche's Genealogy of Morals, you know, yeah, book one, book one, the emergence of
resentment. It's your fault, and what Christianity as a religion does is it comes in and it interiorizes
it turns that it's your it's you know it's someone else's fault to it's my fault, right, in the formation
of bad conscience. So what we have here is this oscillation between resentment it's someone else's
fault and bad conscience it's my fault, right, and the ascetic priest in this case are you know less
religion and maybe corporate America or or or the internet, right, is the thing that's transforming but
it's it's always a question of blame responsibility as the basis of subject formation, like how do you get to be
an eye by being to blame? Yeah, exactly that, yeah, I was gonna add with that too, like that's very, I mean
again I haven't actually read that because I cannot reiterate if I'm not a philosopher, okay, um, but uh
but it's interesting though in regards to religion saying that it kind of turns back the blame on like
you know, it's my fault because like that's kind of like the function of Christianity there is kind
of the the cop out of the potential perfection of like, well there is something we can put it upon, and
that comes back to the whole scapegoat because I feel like that is so intrinsic in that culture
yeah, okay, yeah, because it's just like so like on one hand like yes it does, but and it also comes
back to the whole tension release because there's the tension that like, oh yes, like this is all it's
all my fault, like I'm full of sin, and then you also have it's like, oh, but it's not really because
all I have to do is just say ten Hail Marys and I'm fine, so I think that like it's an interesting
comparison to use religion because I do think unlike corporations which I guess maybe to an
extent corporations apologies and corporations branding is their answer and that's like their
atonement, which I guess also you guys probably figured out like five seconds ago, but you know
with Bo Burnham it all it all comes back well it's like the self-flagellating is like the ten Hail
Marys too, like saying on Twitter that I'm culpable in systemic structures of oppression that's my Hail
Mary for the day and then I'll I'm going to heaven I'm going into woke heaven
you know, but also but but like I mean the flip side and I I know I keep doing this is is like
flipping sides in a sense but it's like what else can you do right like there's no in other words that
that's where I I get back on your self-awareness team for a moment and I'm like look there's there's
no I mean it to me there is something fundamentally different about um you made the distinction between
the the corporate ad for LGBTQ and the sort of Bo Burnham sort of comedy and what he brings to it is
a self-awareness of his own imbrication in the things that he's doing whereas the corporate doesn't
have that and I'm like that's a difference right like that's that's a difference now I'm not saying
it's a determinative difference of what makes one good and one bad I'm not saying that at all but it is
a difference and that self-awareness I mean and and I'm I share this with you Nate like I I find
those things more interesting I find the person who is you know participating in a in a in a problematic
way in whatever cultural phenomenon but is is sort of cognizant of the problems with it I'd rather be
around that person than the one who isn't right right you know and but both are still both are still
participating you could also argue you could also argue that the even the corporation's disingenuous
engagement in woke values is still but it's also maybe a good thing like it points to even though
they feel pressure to be woke uh from like a profit margin kind of uh perspective like that points to
a progressive arc of the country overall so even if they are disingenuous and even if they are still
exploiting labor in various ways I mean that does point to something good happening probably well I
mean and back to the special too I mean it's kind of like an intentionality like you know it doesn't
really matter exactly what the thought process behind or why we're seeing these things I mean it's the
effect that it you know ultimately has on people but at the same time you know like with that self-awareness
and still knowing that they're complicit in those it complicates it um yeah I mean yeah that's where the corporate
Question does an interesting thing because while we can believe and I think wrongly a lot of the times
that individuals simply have intentions I mean for the most part I feel like I act out of a whole
series of intentions that I don't know what they are and they change over time and then later I reflect
back and I think it was completely different but when you're dealing with a large entity like any kind
of company the idea that there's one intention is absurd right like the idea like a Turner Classic
Movies like there's not just one person who makes the you know there are a whole series of people who
have to enact every kind of decision and they can do it with various levels of sincerity and authenticity
or cynicism or disingenuousness or right like you've just got a whole panoply of motives you know
motivations and so the idea of saying well did Ben and Jerry's or did corporation X really mean that is
a it's an absurd question on its face in ways that we don't think it's an absurd question when we
oppose it to individuals my argument is it's exactly the same question
you